you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
that will likely leave a lasting
impression on most chess players
it's the game between Alexander
MacDonald lying his white and Louie
Charles my de la Bourdonnais this was
played in London in 1834 the final
product of this game the final position
is one that is truly remarkable one that
gives us let's say a high dose of
aesthetic appeal to the chess
instructors of the world I believe many
will find this game here as a great way
to illustrate the quality over quantity
and then some and to the casual player I
believe many would be left commenting
with their favorite superlative so let's
see how exactly these two minds over 180
years ago produced such a fantastic
ending that we can still appreciate
today we have MacDonald opening with e4
leborgne a replying with the Sicilian we
have an open Sicilian and now e5 move
for a 5 there are a few names that I'm
aware of connected with this efj I've
move one is Kalashnikov and the other
two Laborde nei Lowenthal so the black
player here laborda nei playing a
variation of the Sicilian he helped
pioneer challenging the centralized
night asking it a question what will you
do
white captures the night black takes
towards the center and after just these
five moves we can identify an important
feature and that is a central majority
two-to-one tipping in blacks favor we
get a few developing moves in minor
pieces coming out
night spinned unpinned Queenie - this is
developing move maybe a bit on the early
side to declare the Queen nights III
would have been fine as well to defend
efore d5 you know that's one of the
things to note the difference between
these two is that after Queenie - black
is able to get that pawn majority in the
center of rolling some d5 it is Bishop
takes Knight Bishop takes Bishop one
question I had at this point is is there
a way for white to win upon like this
the answer is no Queen takes pawn you
drop the bishop and if Bishop takes
Bishop there's the recapture with the
knight defending e5
so on this d5 move it is Bishop takes
Knight Bishop takes Bishop and just nine
moves in there are now two important
features one is still present in that of
the two-two-one regarding the center and
the other is black having now the bishop
pair white drops back both the players
castle and now a5 looks to trap the
bishop who is short on squares white
captures on d5 and after the recapture
we now have an instance of two to zero
in the center rook d1 piling up on d5
and black pushes and now this move
fourteen a very committal one McDonald
opting for c4 seeing this as an
opportunity to get a passed pawn we now
have a case where both sides have a
passed pawn which passed pawn will prove
more decisive Queen b6 some more
development Bishop c2 this pawn is
immune from capture as Bishop h7 his
wits check so the Queen on e2 we can say
is
directly defending be to more
development longest diagonal on the
board pointing at the heart Knight d2
and now rook 88 this is not an
opportunity for black to just win upon
even though that the queen is no longer
there
after a bishop takes h7 to win the Queen
if Queen takes B at this moment instead
of the game move rook a to e8 white can
play first queen d3 pining up a mate
threat and now there is this idea of
rook a one winning the bishop after like
g6 and rook a to be one black has to
know pitch a pawn give the pawn back
with e4 as any Queen move would allow
rook takes Bishop and afteri for we can
take and after Bishop takes Knight rook
takes we would have a opposite color
Bishop roughly equal endgame we don't
have this capture but rather rook 88 94
black preserves the bishop and prepares
f5 kicking the night away white gets
pushing his passed pawn
c5 queen c6 the threat here is to kick
the night and then give made on g2 so f3
a nice pawn structure to blunt this
bishops diagonal Bishop e7 is there to
keep a watchful eye over a knight hop
rook a to c1 getting another piece
involved getting behind this passed pawn
and now here comes f5 this is
challenging the central night of course
and at the same time it is leaving black
of vulnerable along this diagonal there
now a couple checking opportunities for
white and white goes with one of them
Queen c4 and black goes to the corner
Bishop a4 is the follow up with a skewer
did black not see this there is an
opportunity to block with the Queen
however after Bishop b3 King in the
corner there's now Knight d6 the Queen
is no longer around to watch over that
d6 square so black sees this as an
opportunity to yes invest some material
to allow this exchange to allow this
skewer and instead focus on one of the
imbalances in the position that is this
central pawn majority the Queen swings
over to h6 side of the bishops way and
keeps a close eye on this checking
Square III after Bishop takes rook we
have on takes Knight now recapturing
here but instead improving the quality
of the pawns they are creeping a little
bit closer towards this promotion rank
c6 white is pushing with his majority
well not majority he's pushing his
passed pawn attacking the bishop but
this is something that can be ignored
black captures on f3 and white now lends
some defense to his second rank
capturing the bishop allows a mate in
six
starting with Queen III King h1 pawn
takes King takes and here comes the
Queen in rook King g1 we have a
discovered check and then a mate on g2
therefore you cannot capture the Bishop
rook c2 was played Queen e3 check and
now very important moment rook f2 must
be played here but in the game it was
king h1 and this allows black to have
the initiative to have a winning
position better is rook f2
preparing to me captures on g2 with
Queenie to defending King each one was
played Bishop c8 getting out of the
pawns way Bishop d7 black pushes we now
have a case of three passed pawns rook
f1 black continues to push rook c3
Bishop takes Bishop pawn takes e4
they're inching ever closer these three
passed pawns queen c8 Bishop d8 this is
a good way to defend blacks back rank
neither side is with that flight Square
just yet for their kings Queen c4 Queen
e1 rook takes Queen allows the recapture
and promotion to a queen with mate White
needs to defend their back rank clearly
queen is attacked twice now black
ignores this and continues pushing
doesn't matter which way you capture the
Queen Black is getting a new one and
defending with a pawn purpo takes rook
you're getting a queen you're getting a
queen again she's going nowhere very
well supported Queen clearly Queen c5
threatening a mate in one
rook g8 at this point these two pieces
really aren't needed the Queen and these
three pawns alone are enough rook d1 d3
queen c3 and now Queen takes rook rook
takes Queen in the final move of the
game e - this is the position that is
truly remarkable to have a case of three
passed pawns a single step away from
queening it is at this point that white
resigns it is at this point that white
realized
the Queen and the rook are not enough to
fend off against three past pawns of
this great depth these three ponds that
have such a great quality to them
of course what to do here it's already
me reading as a million five the
suggestion is to create a flight square
there's just too many different ways
black can go ahead and promote from here
II won capture the rook f1
you can't defend all these threats Queen
takes pawn its f1 and then recapture
promote and give me H four takes King h2
we're getting another Queen and he's
going to be dead very soon
so clearly a fantastic finish to this
one what exactly helped lead to that
final position we have a look just to
see this one real quick from the winning
side here it's black one of the first
things is that white helped build black
center we have that two-to-one majority
in the center very early on we also have
this Bishop pair if you're going to
invest the bishop pair one of the things
you ought to look at is you know this
the white side they invested the bishop
pair one of the things to look at is my
knight is there a good outpost for him
in the game where was that outpost it
wasn't there you should be looking for a
hole within blacks position for this
night to get to a square that he can
rely upon there wasn't it wasn't really
that in the position the knight
struggled to do anything in this one and
this was a very committed decision this
prawn was not nearly as effective as
this strong pawn on d4 note that black
has the support of this pawn with
another one of his pawns whereas the
b-pawn never quite got rolling for white
and as mentioned this Knight this isn't
a reliable home white tries to get that
square but
it's covered with the bishop and
eventually he gets kicked away this is
where white goes in for the tactical
opportunity with the skewer but we're
seeing a case here where the quality of
the pawns here it's it's worthwhile to
invest some material in order to advance
your Trump in this case this central
pawn majority black does just that and
what a fantastic finish we had with
these three connected passed pawns just
a single square away from queening and
they were no match for the Queen and
rook
so clearly an excellent game I hope you
enjoyed it feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you